ينضم الينا من عمان لواء فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه لواء الدويري اليوم كان
هناك
تصعيد كبير جدا بالمسيرات الروسيه على
العاصمه الاوكرانيه ما الذي تريد موسكو
تحقيقه من وراء ذلك
يعني هناك مجموعه من العوامل
تجعل المتابع والمراقب لا يستغرب ما حدث
من هجمات في هذا اليوم يعني اذا فقط
مقارنه بسيطه في الظروف المحيطه قبل سته
اشهر عندما تم تدمير جسر كيرش كان الرد
عنيف جدا الان هناك ثلاثه عوامل او ثلاثه
امور محفزه لروسيا لتنفذ هكذا هجوم وقد
يكون كما اشاره التقرير الغد اسوا واصعب
اولا الرد على مهاجمه
وبالتالي هو رمز السياده الوطنيه فاذا
لابد ان يكون هناك رد عنيف واشرنا لذلك في
تلك اللحظه الامر الاخر غدا يوم النصر
واحتفالات النصر ولم يستطع لافاجنر ولا
الجيش الروسي ان يقدم هديه الى الرئيس
بوتين على الاقل هديه متواضعه اعلان
السيطره على باكمون يجب ان يقدم شيء اخر
الامر الثالث الحديث كثر عنه هجوم الربيع
وبالتالي هذه الهجمات
ستسبب ارباكا ولو كان محدودا على النطاق
السياسي
والاستراتيجيه العسكريه اي بمعنى اخر
محاوله احباط او على الاقل التدخل في
التحذيرات النهائيه للهجوم القادم الذي
تتحدث عنه كل وسائل الاعلام ولكن لماذا
كان هناك جنرالات وعائلاتهم
غادروا المنطقه على عجل ما هي مخاوف روسيا
يعني كان هناك عمليه اجلاما 18 بلده وقريه
خلال الاسبوع الماضي وبدايه هذا الاسبوع
لان كثر الحديث عن العملي العسكري
المرتقبه
ولم يعد هناك ما يمكن ان نطلق عليه
المفاجاه الاستراتيجيه المنطقه المتوقع شن
الهجوم بها اصبحت شبه معروفه او مؤكده ما
لم يحدث تغييرا في الخطه في اللحظات
الاخيره وهذه المنطقه تمتد تقريبا من محطه
زفروجيا في الشمال الشرقي الى خرس في
الجنوب الغربي باتجاه ميلوتوبل وشبه جزيره
القرم هذه المنطقه
التي تزيد يزيد عرضها عن اكثر من 150 الى
170 كيلو متر هذه ستكون منطقه عمليات اذا
لابد من تحضيرها وقد بدا الجيش الروسي
بتحضيرها حيث بنى ثلاث خطوط دفاعيه بعمق
الى اربعين كيلو متر وبطول 120 كيلو متر
لكل خط دفاعي اذا لابد من اجلاء عائلات
القاده وما شابه ذلك ليتفرغ القائد ويكون
لديه القدره على التركيز في اداء واجباته
واداره المعركه
هل تعتقد بانه سينفذ تهديده
وينسحب من المنطقه اذا كان فعلا هناك
عمليات مكثفه للجيش الروسي سيقوم بها في
ذكرى يوم النصر
لا هو منذ يوم امس
صرح بكل وضوح انه تم تلبيه طلال هذه
الطلبات وتم تعيين الجناره التركي وهو على
علاقه طيبه بهذا الجنرال مسؤولا عن
التنسيق فيما يتعلق باعاده الامداد
وبالتالي هو انا اعتبر ان ماجره ومناوره
من بريجوجن من اجل الوصول الى تحقيق اهداف
وما كانت الحجه هو نقص الذخيره الا قمه
جبل الجليد على الخلافات التي بينه وبين
شويغو ورئيس الاركان شكرا لك فايزه
الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
وشكرا لك على الافاده